all right let's get into the week's
mailbag you can always email info
davidpakman.com we have a variety a
smattering of different thoughts and
prayers and emails and different things
to look at this week
occasionally we will look at youtube
comments or tweets or whatever the case
may be but mostly emails all right let's
go to our first one mary wrote in about
donald trump and said i loved his alaska
rally and i hated all your little stupid
comments on the side i think you're a
complete idiot well
two points to marry for correctly using
the contraction of you are y o u
apostrophe r e it's almost a legal
requirement when you send me hate mail
that you incorrectly put in y-o-u-r we
see that almost every day so mary
congrats as a reminder
i will say whatever the hell i want
during my streams and if you don't like
it find a different stream this is my
stream at the end of the day and i'm
allowed to talk over your president as
you like to refer to him as much as i
want
thank you mary
mike from new york city wrote in about
the who is the president question and
says big fan of the show recently you
asked election fraud
conspiratorialist darlene swaffer who is
the president how is this question asked
in better faith than republicans who ask
what is a woman when hearing testimonies
from trans advocates aren't they both
gotcha questions
no mike who is the president is not a
gotcha question
when i ask who is the president it's a
good faith
check as to whether they can
tell me a simple fact it's sort of like
do humans need water to live it's a yes
or no question these these are not trick
questions and if they are unable to
answer it it really says something about
them the what is a woman question is a
question that's deliberately contrived
first of all to blow up an issue that is
a minor political issue that's number
one and then number two
um it's a question
that is being asked
out of context and then misused to
answer questions that are either legal
questions or questions of competition in
sports or about abortion or whatever the
case it's the epitome of bad faith when
i say who's the president if they go the
president's joe biden go
fine i'm not go looking to use that in
any particular way it's the opposite of
a bad faith question so no there's
really no similarity there whatsoever
aaron wrote in about donald trump's
dancing says hey david it's aaron from
hull england i've been to hull
from hull england writing huge fan of
the show i was wondering what your
thoughts are on donald trump's dancing
after rallies it's always perplexed me
as to his motives behind the dancing do
you think it's to come across as more
affable or light-hearted i'd love to
hear your thoughts on the reasons behind
his dancing no here's what it is with
trump and his dancing trump
not accidentally but on a whim
trump danced for like five seconds once
at a rally
and
his the crowd liked it
and it started to be memed and his
supporters loved it and
he got the attention that he wanted for
it positive attention rather than
negative attention and so he just does
it all the time that that's all that you
have to
the lens through which we interpret all
of these actions by trump
is a lens of self-centered narcissism
that's fundamentally the the most
important thing
and so the reason trump does anything is
to get what he hopes and believes is or
will be positive attention and he even
does it the dancing now
at horrible
times like he danced at the end he spoke
at the nra
72 hours after the horrible texas
shooting
uh made a mockery of everything at the
speech and then danced after the fact
it's all in poor taste it's all for
self-aggrandizement
kyle wrote in
kyle says hey i need to talk about
something my mom's cousin sends her
stupid political stuff
and my mom thinks 75 percent of
democrats regret the way they voted
i don't think that's an accurate
statistic at all what do you think what
would you say
her cousin is always sending her stupid
political crap yeah so listen it's hard
to debunk things i haven't seen but i
have seen no evidence whatsoever that 75
percent of democrats regret voting for
biden over trump i am not a democrat but
i'm on the left i voted for biden over
trump do i think biden is the best thing
since sliced cracked wheat bread no
is biden the best thing since nova
smoked salmon no of course not
um but was it obviously the right
decision given the given the alternative
110 percent so it sounds completely made
up
if you look at biden's approval of 37
percent 37 percent is low
but there's no way that
the vast majority of the disapproval is
republicans so you have to sort of see
if these numbers pass the sniff test if
of the 63 percent it's really some
people have no opinion so it's like high
50s but of the 60 percent that
disapprove of biden's handling as
president
most are republicans and so you have to
realize by that alone
it just doesn't make sense that 75 of
democrats regret voting for joe biden so
ask her to provide a source is the best
advice i can give you violence if trump
is indicted this came up on the show the
other day
and a viewer doesn't think i should be
talking about it
who said quote i think it's smarter
not to talk about that the democrats are
cowards enough for many and all threats
the republicans make do you want them to
really think about these potential
threats when evaluating whether or not
to indict trump think that's smart i
don't but love your thoughts most of the
time yeah listen um merrick garland is
not considering
whether trumpists will be violent
in terms of figuring out whether he
wants to indict donald trump i think
merrick garland is thinking more about
his uh career
and how it will look for a department of
justice to indict a former president i
don't think that it's a factor and one
of the things i won't do on this show is
sort of like strategically hide things
from you for optics reasons i believe
there's a real chance that if trump is
indicted republicans will get violent
i'm not going to hide that
um
it's a topic of discussion it's a very
real one after january 6th in particular
so i think the smartest thing i can do
is to be honest with the audience and to
say what i believe the truth to be
and what i believe is likely to happen
in the future
a millie wrote in about gavin newsom
and says dear mr pakman i agree with you
about gavin newsom for 2024. what do you
think about pete budege actually the
they called him booted leg booty leg but
i call him boot edge edge for vice
president i think they would make a
powerful team watch your show daily keep
up the good work best to you and yours
amy yeah i mean listen
if you want to make an identity politics
argument it's like two more white guys
what
um the reality is that gavin newsom and
p buddha judge are too highly highly
skilled politicians
they play offense rather than defense
which the democratic party desperately
needs right now now in terms of boot
edge edge for vice president
but normally i wouldn't even be talking
about 2024 before the 2022 midterms
because the two elections are so linked
we're talking about both
in relation to each other i've said i
think newsom is a skilled politician who
could be interesting in 24 i think
buddha is a skilled politician who could
be interesting in 2024 so let's first
figure out the nominee
let's deal with vp later
but there is no question that buddha
judge is a very good when he goes on fox
news at just completely disarming and
disassembling these contrived right-wing
framings of issues and that's really
what they are
nathan wrote in about right-wing
derangement here's nathan's theory
theory the right wants to make the
entire middle of the country
uninhabitable for all but the hardest
right of the right-wing nut jobs forcing
reasonable humans to fewer and fewer
states on the coasts enshrining minority
rule
solidifying indefinite control over the
senate all future judicial appointments
and clinging to fascistic power
indefinitely could this be why there
seems to be no bottom to the absolutely
depraved arranged policy positions
they're willing to take so there is no
bottom to their depravity nathan's right
about that but this doesn't seem like
what the idea here is republicans want
to make red states so horrible for
liberals that all the liberals leave
now in the senate that can be useful
because you can increasingly have
minority rule wherein
uh a minority of where senators
representing a minority of the
population
control more than half the senate we've
talked about that math the math works in
the senate the problem is if all the red
states lose population
at the census
they will lose
members of the house
and that's not good for them and also
it doesn't help them win uh presidential
elections
so i i i think they would have no qualms
morally about approaching uh
employing such a strategy nathan but i
don't think they're doing it i don't
even know that they're that organized
and also it doesn't really seem like it
would work when you look at the math of
it
blake wrote in blake says i'm a
subscriber and i very much appreciate
and agree mostly with your show
however i also respect and appreciate dr
joseph mercola i'm not sure why some of
the left has trouble with dr mercola it
would be incredibly educational
if you could critically
interview him thanks for reading yeah i
mean the thing about dr mercola is he's
one of the most notorious anti-vaccine
anti-science voices
in the sort of like quack community
so it's not for me
it's just not for me
last one anthony says trump says that
investigations of him are politically
motivated so what if an investigation is
into his activities reveals a crime what
does it matter if the investigation was
politically motivated well it doesn't
matter if it's politically motivated in
terms of the criminality what we
wouldn't want is a crime committed by a
hundred people
where only republicans or democrats are
targeted for it that would be a problem
trump's crimes are highly political and
in that sense it's not
the wrong term to say politically
motivated but the problem with political
motivation is when we talk about
unfair application of the law it's not
what's happening with trump that's for
sure we've got a great bonus show for
you today
sign up at joinpakman.com use the coupon
code bigvoting22 i will see you then